it seems mariah carey is sending a
message after her ex nick cannon
seemingly attempts to win her back i was
like
why are you so obsessed with me
mariah got all lovey-dovey on insta for
valentine's day sharing this coupled-up
moment with her man brian tanaka mimi's
long time boo also shared this shot
calling mariah my valentine but fans
couldn't help but notice the timing of
the posts the singer and dancer snuggled
up for some online pda just a day after
mariah's ex-husband nick cannon released
his new song alone take a listen
yeah pretty much everyone on twitter
took those lyrics and assumed nick's
trying to win mariah back the song even
samples mariah's 1990 hit love takes
time
[Music]
but the talk show host clarified his new
track on his show
i did a song called alone
and it sampled one of my favorite mariah
carey songs love takes time and so i
think people put the two to two together
and everybody's saying that this was my
song to try to get mariah back
i know that's that's impossible i have
my dream girl and i messed it up so
don't don't clap for that
the song wasn't really about trying to
get it back it's really it was taking
ownership of what i did as a man and
owning my flaws on it
and expressing it through songs mariah
and nick separated in 2014 after six
years of marriage in 2011 they became
parents to twins moroccan and monroe aka
dem babies you know we all we made some
amazing children together you did and
e.t was there in 2013 when they renewed
their vows at disneyland with their
kiddos
five years ago
mariah and nick wished upon a star
and a dream came true for them on their
wedding day and today
here we go
and today their magical dream continues
fast forward to 2016 and mariah spilled
to e.t about co-parenting with nick it's
just about being really nice with the
other parent and not making it like a
competition or anything like that and
get this in 2020 nick revealed if his ex
ever gives him dating advice
has mariah given you any tips on dating
yeah don't do it
now i feel like she i feel like that's
that's still family for life so like you
know we when we when we talk those
subject matters come up we just kind of
avoid them okay
so with that said we're guessing mariah
and nick probably haven't chatted about
alone if i could go back to where we
started
[Music]